[Music]
you can't defeat me
no i know
but he can't
[Music]
on your left
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
where have you been everybody thought
you were dead
if we can't accept limitations we're
boundaries we're no better than the bad
guys but it's run by people with agendas
and agendas change that's good that's
why i'm here when i realized what my
weapons were capable of in the wrong
hands if we sign this we surrender our
right to choose
we may not be perfect but the safest
hands are still our own
provided support to the allies when they
needed it most
some would say it brought our country
closer to war
see if not for these you wouldn't be
here
[Music]
buddy
you all right yes i'm fine why why is
this donut look all right you look like
melted ice cream
so what's up just over a hangover
thank you mr stark
but i'm i'm good
you're good good how are you good
somebody's got to look out for the
little guy right
you turned me down you better think
about this look at that
look at me
last chance yes or no no okay
it's kind of a springsteen working class
your own vibe that i dig
stick a needle in that kid's arm it's
gonna go right through on girls
look at that
he's making me cry
i am looking for qualities but arms are
physical
[Music]
[Music]
that's 100.
[Music]
oh
[Music]
return to the jump point
[Music]
okay
who here hasn't been to space
you better not throw up on my ship
approaching jump in three
two
one
[Music]
appears to be a standard sequence
violation
hands up
you're coming with us this is actually
your last chance
now get out of my way
what
i i see this is an absolute win
oh my god get that thing away how'd that
get in here
the cat
this isn't what you're afraid of is it
that's the only cat
that's a fluke a flurking
i've mastered the ability
of standing so incredibly still
that i've become invisible to the eye
but my movement
was so slow
that it's imperceptible
[Music]
i'm sure i'm invisible hi drugs
[Music]
[Music]
you